voilà
de bien voilà il va manger
tranquillement
à droite dans le coin à droite
tu verras très jolie
ça comme ça voilà
alors
regarde à droite comme c'est plus beau
tu vois regarde tu as vu tu es le bordel
en haut de l'image en haut à gauche et
qui vient vers le marais qui sont
sur les bords d'image c'est
on va être obligé
voilà voilà comme ça c'est beau tu vois
regarde tous à la gauche de l'animal tu
vois regarde on va le refaire tant qu'il
regarde à gauche l'animal comme c'est
beau tu vois comme c'est beau à gauche
partir sur l'antilope et découvrir le
plan général pas que je vois l'antilope
qui est couché qui est super à l'aise et
maintenant va doucement
voilà
c'est très serré desserrer dessus
c'est bon voilà
et maintenant les cartes toi il va sur
le les découvre tout le tout tout le bar
et voilà
donc à sa droite voilà pas trop à sa
droite à sa droite à droite
voilà comme ça voilà voilà
tu le vois ou pas tu la vois ou pas
couché c'est génial qui est tranquille
il y a pas peur de nous du tout comme ça
et tu la feras partir en partiras partir
voilà reste là comme ça voilà c'est joli
ça voilà c'est ça joli plan ça voilà là
c'est beau ça c'est magnifique ça
je suis obligé de le lâcher
exactement
et on passe
de quoi on va venir dedans
que le pilote le voit et qui fasse
passer le soleil dedans
c'est super beau autour il y a plein de
c'est super beau ça comme endroit
on va passer un peu oui
à ma gauche je le vois il va la voir
mais quand un jour je le vois où il est
ok let's go
attention on rate pas on rate pas on
rate pas ça passe en plein dedans voilà
autre jour est là il est là il est là il
est là il est là il est là il est là il
est là et il part et on laisse partir le
truc
il est beau il est beau
c'est bon
allez balance de l'essence depuis la
rivière quoi
j'ai l'essence les mecs
de la rivière parce que la rivière qui
fait arrêter